herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
videoleuchte ihr kennt vielleicht das
zelt empire wir haben eine wand
aufgebaut neben jetzt ein platz frei das
erinnert alles an wer kann besser lügen
aber ihr kennt vielleicht auch hier
vorne steht eine hülle von dessen nichts
weil ihr hat hier schon mal ein video
zusagen gemacht heute kommt das zweite
video und wir spielen während wird
dessen die 2 zocken eine werke besser
lügen challenge also die extrem version
und wer ist mein heutiger gast fragt ihr
euch bestimmt ich bitte dich lieber gast
koma ins bild rein das ist jemand dir
wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht denn das
ist ja nun die kollege von mir wie ihr
gleich den fans seit dem letzten dessen
die video ziemlich viel gezockt und ich
habe ungefähr alles zusammen mit jan
gespielt und deshalb sind wir so relativ
eingespielt miteinander aber heute
gegeneinander wieder voll funktioniert
ihr kennt vielleicht schon mal nach
einem gegenstand vor sich liegen
beschreibt diesen und der andere muss
erraten ob es richtig oder falsch ist
also auch der gegenstand vielleicht
sogar erfunden ist ja und die
gegenstände geben uns sebastian rein
damit ich sagen staaten niemals so leute
wir betreten jetzt die runde und jetzt
heißt es wer kann mitmachen und dabei
besser lügen sebastian macht schon
bereit uns die gegenstände zu geben ich
würde sagen du erstmal die bei bedarf es
einer mal anfangen die pflicht sind erst
nächsten gleich den wir im spiel sein
und ich muss dazu sagen du hast dich in
den letzten tagen ein bisschen
eingezogen weil ja ich hab gestern die
dann in der lisson ich bin viel spricht
vor lauter uni gar nicht so wirklich
reinkommt in den westen
tagen also weißt du vielleicht anfangen
jetzt im vorteil aber sagt er dauert
keine kein 2.0 sind wieder am start so
ich bin ja bekanntlicherweise dollar
die anbieter alles klar dann würde ich
sagen ja ich wünsche dir viel erfolg
also natürlich nicht für misserfolg und
ich war mit dem ersten gegner den es zu
erraten gibt machte weise geräusche wenn
ich halt wie ich irgendwas ableger oder
so nichts hast du mir schon das erste
gegeben die alle den ersten gegenstand
da wo man eben ein e-piano ist es bei
den fußball fans muss herausfinden ob du
liegst du damit der erste gegner nicht
da und ja erzählt was ich liebe vettel
hat nun zehn gericht einfach eine münze
und zwar sind die pausen manchmal ein
bisschen lang gesagt das was für dich
vielleicht packt leute auf mich ich sage
einfach mal weil sebastian nicht so viel
geld hat das belege gesammelt gemacht
geschickt überhaupt ist und jetzt kriegt
max den ersten die nord längst im keller
aber was für ein etwas so schwebt ja
nicht hin übers ufer kette und das ist
damit hilfe ein publikum war vom körper
fahrbahn zu den ersten gegen statt da
und ja nicht ich sehe den ersten
gegenstand ganz kurz muss noch ein thema
ich bin so schlecht bin so schlecht kann
unser hab und gut dass ich ein bisschen
zu sehr viel zeit
das ist unerklärlich hat vor mir liegen
die fernbedienung vom fernseher auf den
mietspiegel genauer erklären
auf der linken seite wunderbar ist
lautstärke tasten und ein mattes finish
in izmir fingerabdrücke so nein nicht
weiß welche folgen die tempi liegt
einfach die grünen surfen sofern aber
daneben
das internet fingerabdrücke drauf
verdacht zumal ja es war meine klasse
von daher person und dazu auch noch nur
einen akt schicken viel gestorben in den
herzen games sehr gut auf jeden fall so
die stadt weiter und zwar mal ist muss
wieder laut sein damit ja nicht etwas
vergisst
der nächste gegenstand ist daher und
jannis hingelegt was genau soll das
papier für die boni auf geschrieben hast
du was zuvor das lag hier im raum dass
meistens definitiv also es ist ja auch
wieder so spezifisch mehr so erlebt ich
mache ich gar kein kind ich muss
eigentlich die sachen verraten aber ich
meine das reicht jedoch nicht zu sagen
als ich irgendwann papieren also muss
schon die fertigen bestimmt das wäre ja
genau ich sage einfach mal ich sage das
stimmt nicht korrekt es ist einfach ein
einkaufs belegt aktuell den stop wieder
auf die seite der schönen kate für leute
so muss das ja nicht dass du aktuell
ich bin noch über dir jetzt ist sicher
dass das die beste lösung das hier
richtig das ist der hintergrund häufig
wird hier bist du schrecklich leute ich
muss wieder in der letzten die spiele
mit der kraft und olaf scholz spd jetzt
leute aber ich bin zwar so schlecht aber
ich mache die kosten paket ist kein
problem nächste gegner für max kommt
jetzt und jahre und materialität was
hast du das denn hier also wollen wir
liegt schon verlieren
die sofort mirabelle was für einer ist
der denker der klassische genau alles
wieder mazda ist recht schmal ist
ich bin nicht sicher ob ich hoffe dass
ich besitze auch berichtet dass du dein
ganzer als solcher server und moment
moment ich habe viel musik gegner ghana
hat auch viel musik begegnet sicher ich
habe einfach fertig nun dass alles okay
aber das ist nur die erste runde das war
nur die erste sondern gehen weiter und
somit den gegenstand für januar mussten
wird diese sagen also heute ist es so
schwierig zu zocken und dabei noch die
sich irgendwelche geschichten
auszudenken
aber das ist die schwierigkeit löcher
entfernt sagt so was und zwar agiere
hier den treffen radierer einfach via
iphone hatte schreiten hand in sich weiß
und blau weiße markierung weist ganz
normal gesehen
noch immer zieht meine seite schüler
eine solche vielleicht blau blau weiß
setzte nicht mehr gesagt so ein besitze
ich kann daher sein gemüt es ist leider
war es war
inhaltlich hatte zu früh fit während
sich das weiterhin ja sie haben das
bleibe auch jetzt noch mal hast du blau
weißen dann blau rot gesagt ja weiß
roman ich sag mal ein bisschen blau
roten am ende weiß gesagt dass eben auch
die schwierigkeiten an die ganze stadt
und verein ist kann auch nicht richtig
zuhört oder was nein wert der milch oha
verletzlich schlechte sind wir sind
richtig deutet wir sind ohne spaß wenn
wir einfach zu zweit konzentriert
spielen könnte müsste was nicht genannt
wird immer toptraker so weiter geht s
leute sagt schönmetzler nächster
gegenstand kann und mag sich jetzt bei
büroartikel blieben oder falls es nicht
und zwar ist es ein
ja schon in klebeband spender
beschreiben
das ist dass spender musikalische rolle
der ausstieg zum hafen kann jetzt
abreißen
ja so einer in rot und stadtbesucher
geblieben ich weiß dass du so einen hass
aber das weißt du hast du viel zu gerne
nix also ich glaube dir bestimmt und das
ist korrekt ist tatsächlich die pubertät
zu sagen möchte weil ich damit passen
aber trotz 200 ist einfach der nächste
gegen statuieren jetzt ist eigentlich
gleich nein eigentlich dahin schon
wieder unsere erst ein zimmer
ich habe keinen bruder haben gleisbett
bebra auf meinem büro größtes und dachte
ich mir auf ok
der war auch auf jeden fall in dem
zimmer aber der fertig doch gehört sowas
groß und ich sage meinen lieber ja das
ist ja einfach gemacht und das ist die
wahrheit erzählt julia sahin der nach
der pilot und jünger ist der motor kalt
oder höheren widerstand naja ich habe
ihn die ganze zeit meine super und
kriegt einfach nicht gebacken die
vernünftig einzusetzen ich hatte gerade
richtig richtig abliefern können dann
kommt das hier macht die seite und der
nächste gegner macht comics ist habe ich
schon verpasst hast du jetzt
für max liegt bei ihm frau so was hast
du ja das ist ja schon mal was diese
eile sagt der sc das verstehe ich jetzt
nächsten ganz schön verrückt dagegen
standen ich habe mich sehr dass ich habe
vor mir hingelegt eine packung
taschentücher okay soweit bekannt dass
man das richtige
auf youtube sind in jedem zimmer der box
dann verstehen wir wissen warum der
eigentlich muss bmw gs den kram gekommen
gott jetzt kommst bist schon die letzte
runde hat der schweizer schnell ist eine
das land es ist eine packend vortrag
hören kommt leider pech gehabt und jetzt
schauen wir wer hat mir tipps macht
garantiert du ja 111 ps ich würde sagen
da die gefühlt circa unentschieden war
bei dem geht der erste sieg in der
destination sich die gratuliere dir sehr
herzen danke dass du dabei warst so und
natürlich sagen das war's von häufigen
video und jan hat gewonnen
wir sehen uns nicht mehr sinnvoll
möglich geworden aber ich sagen also bei
guter gastgeber wind mit dabei war es
nicht sein dass du mit musik passt als
erster auf der iss in zwei bekommen
gerade ist ein neues herausgekommen das
heißt eine erweiterung zur story die ja
nicht schon durch und werden jetzt die
auch in angriff nehmen ihr könnt
zusätzlich auf jeder plattform kopf
voran playstation 4 und pc der sony als
demo kostenlos aus festen und also
vergeben alle links in die beschreibung
das war es dann eigentlich auch von
unseren heute vielleicht kommen ja
häufiger mal das licht durch das wieder
richtig dran sind als dann sehen wir uns